call this my friends is what we use
booth the old old times
what's up peeps so I think these are for
the cameras and you put these in front
of the cameras they're just like
old-school tiles it's like this rocket
on use the old walkie-talkie whoops look
guys
these are rocket ah here's our first
detectives oh it was used for the army
it's like cuz then you can you have your
contacts you can just press your contact
button and then you just call your
friends
[Music]
I figured that this would go away to
here you put it inside and then you can
like in the morning you can like hear
our news this is something you
definitely used to watch something oh I
can explore it a little bit how do you
take that oh there it is that's
complicated I just press the button and
boom
Oh use it to call people this is like a
really old old days you used to put out
there here and you have to use like like
this to get the number on Overton see
like what if someone's robbing your
house we do big nine oh no wrong and if
you mess up Huh What are you doing this
up I feel so bad for Madonna she's old
Madonna has to use this type of food
sorry Madonna I don't know if you're
still alive but I think they were taller
that's applause because it's like Fitbit
and then wouldn't you have to pull it
cops
42 ecofree this year you've got
criminals on dougie second street go go
go do the roof and criminals continues -
hey I just found the bag how we doing
that's once to do eight - twice to do
these that would take forever and ever
and ever and ever but these were cool if
it's all you have
I am this
looks fun c'mon Bo Peep Show
[Music]
t-man t-man good cheap makeup - yeah by
tomorrow hitch a ride
I know whether you are there called Tama
goat cheese it's just boring you just
press buttons just oh we do I'm so glad
I was born in 2005 water lies I don't
want to be weird in the 1980s I feel bad
on my teachers and my parents
[Music]
you